foreign
welcome back to Harry Potter Theory
today we're going to be discussing a
question that I'm sure is at the
Forefront of many Harry Potter fans
Minds who is more powerful Voldemort or
Dumbledore Voldemort and Dumbledore are
the yin and yang of wizards each
extremely powerful and a strong
representative of the classic
relationship between good and evil each
one acting as a symbol for the
invariable struggle between light and
darkness we know how Harry Potter ends
we know that Voldemort is unsuccessful
in securing a shroud of Darkness over
the world but that doesn't mean that he
couldn't have been the most powerful
wizard of all time and the fact that
light prevailed doesn't mean that
Dumbledore was the most powerful wizard
either we've got to look deeper many
assume that because Voldemort ultimately
lost and because Dumbledore is good that
Dumbledore is the more powerful figure
however this is not a sound argument
whether your good or evil has nothing to
do with your inherent power from an
extremely young age Tom Riddle showcased
intensely powerful innate magical
abilities he was a magical Prodigy if
you will as he grew older and he began
to harness his abilities riddle became
unimaginably powerful performing Feats
of magic that people thought previously
impossible and he knew it too
proclaiming to Harry in the air of
Southern that he was the greatest
sorcerer in the world to which Harry
retorts Dumbledore is the greatest
sorcerer in the world reminding riddle
of Dumbledore and subsequently angering
him in my view this anger showed
insecurity in riddle Harry's statement
reminding him of Dumbledore's power
forced him to consider his own magical
ability in relation to Dumbledore's I
think that he a knows that Dumbledore
was more powerful and became angry
because he resented or B is just
completely unsure of whether or not
Dumbledore is more powerful and face it
as a possibility while Voldemort showed
extreme magical prowess from a young age
he was not alone Dumbledore's magical
abilities consistently turned heads at
Hogwarts as well particularly his skills
surrounding charms and Transfiguration
he also did exceptionally well on his
nudes and Griselda marchbanks a
professor working for the Wizarding
examinations Authority remarked that
Albus was able to do things with a wand
that she had never seen before not only
that but Dumbledore befriended
Grindelwald at a very young age and I
believe that this had a profound impact
on Dumbledore's skill the two spent lots
of time together practicing magic and
Grindelwald was known to have come from
a powerful magical bloodline his great
aunt batilde bagshot publishing a
history of magic a magic Book used to
teach students at Hogwarts Dumbledore
who always outshone everyone magically
was challenged by another for the first
time and I believed that this resulted
in even greater power for the both of
them so we know that both of them were
powerful right from the start showing an
innate capability for magic and an
affinity for learning new skills and
abilities so where does this leave us
how can we definitively determine who
was more powerful Dumbledore was known
for being all too modest and in the
first book there is a moment where I
believe it is partially suggested that
Dumbledore is the more powerful sorcerer
or if not more powerful possessing the
inherent capability to be more powerful
if he so desired McGonagall says to
Dumbledore but you're different everyone
knows you're the only one you know oh
all right Voldemort was frightened of
you flatter me said Dumbledore calmly
Voldemort had powers I will never have
to which McGonagall replies only because
you're too well Noble to use them to me
this hints that perhaps Dumbledore has a
higher overall threshold for power than
Voldemort but then he is perhaps not
willing to make the same sacrifices and
for that reason never achieving quite
the same level of power Voldemort's
level of power was achieved by any means
possible with no exceptions his pursuit
of power was filled with ignorance
showing disregard for the consequences
of the pursuit of dark magic he delved
further into the darkness than anyone
before him and he became powerful
because of it but perhaps at too great a
cost in the pursuit of power he lost
himself
however even though he plunged himself
into magic as much as possible Voldemort
at no point in the books films appears
to exhibit magical ability that far
exceeds or outweighs Dumbledore the only
real point of reference that we have
comes from their duel in the ministry
Atrium but there's also sort of
complicates things further I say this
because the jewel is depicted very
differently from book to film with film
Dumbledore coming across as a bit of a
frail old man and a book Dumbledore
absolutely wiping the floor with
Voldemort when they fight in the
ministry Atrium in the film it's left
very open they actually seem evenly
matched for the most part though I would
argue that Voldemort slightly edges him
out when they meet each other in the
atrium Dumbledore and Voldemort
instantly enter into a magical power
struggle with one flick of their ones
Dumbledore's red jet of light met
Voldemort's green jet in mid-air and the
two held their ground as Spa marks flew
and the room began to Fall to Pieces
unable to contain the sheer magical
power being produced the pair basically
appeared to be evenly matched I'd also
like to add that during their duel in
the film there isn't much talking this
is another point that deviates quite a
lot from the book and I think it is a
piece of evidence that was suggest
Dumbledore's superiority throughout
their duel the books continuously
describe Dumbledore's nonchalant
attitude toward everything going on here
he is faced head to head with one of the
darkest and most powerful wizards of all
time but he's so calm in the passage
describing their duel when he walks
toward Voldemort it's constantly
reinforced that he's calm and that he
had not a fear in the world Dumbledore's
demeanor toward Voldemort during their
duel was even described as though they
were discussing the matter over drinks
the books would lead us to believe that
Dumbledore is far superior to Voldemort
and that Voldemort was completely
outmatched however the there are a few
things to consider here one Dumbledore
was in possession of the Elder Wand the
Elder Wand was the most powerful wand in
existence and it's entirely possible
that this could have accounted for the
difference in power between them in fact
based on how film Voldemort performed
against film Dumbledore I'd venture to
say that film Voldemort is stronger
however it is certainly difficult to
quantify just how much of a boost you
get from the powerful magical artifact
two even book Voldemort had a moment
where he made Dumbledore look a bit
silly look out Harry yelled but even as
he shouted another jet of green light
flew at Dumbledore from Voldemort's wand
and the snake struck Forks swooped down
in front of Dumbledore opened his beak
wide and swallowed the jet of Greenlight
whole He burst into flame and fell to
the floor small wrinkled and flightless
this part is particularly interesting
because it actually actually seems to
paint Dumbledore in a little bit more of
a vulnerable state and I think that it
suggests that Dumbledore was perhaps too
confident at the beginning of the jewel
in the film adaptation at no point to
stumbledore need forks to show up and
save him from one of Voldemort's attacks
but what the text shows us is that had
folks not been there Dumbledore would
have either been hit with the Vada
cadavera or the fiery snakes Bell as
both were being directed at him at once
I feel that this is of particular
importance as it may even indicate the
Dumbledore was the loser of their duel a
Forks blocked a spell from hitting him
and unless Dumbledore really didn't need
folks to do that it suggests that he may
have been the loser but bearing the two
points above in mind we do also have to
remember that both versions of
Dumbledore weren't trying to defeat
Voldemort simply Ward him off I think
that if we had these Wizards Jewel 100
times we'd get some pretty interesting
outcomes particularly if we tossed an
Elder Wand into Voldemort's hands as
well I also think that the answer to
this question sort of goes both ways
I'll give you the film answer and the
book answer the film answer is that
Voldemort is more powerful I say this
because in the film Voldemort appears to
have been slightly edging out Dumbledore
despite Dumbledore's possession of the
Elder Wand but I will add that
Dumbledore wasn't trying to kill him so
it's plausible that a proper duel
between both men would likely result in
a stalemate the book answer is almost
definitively that Dumbledore is more
powerful I say this because even though
Voldemort got a decent shot at
Dumbledore and even though Dumbledore
was saved by folks the book passages are
unwavering in their claims that this
Jewel wasn't a big deal for him I think
that folks save giving him probably
wasn't really necessary and it can
probably be chalked up to a Touch Too
Much overconfidence on Dumbledore's part
however with these two answers in mind I
do have a hot take which is that
Voldemort had he lived longer could have
become more powerful than Dumbledore
Voldemort had access to an entire other
side of the magical Spectrum dark magic
aside The Dumbledore who dabbled in his
youth wouldn't dare delve into again in
this respect Dumbledore is limited
whereas Voldemort had access to anything
and everything this is also based on an
extended timeline where Voldemort gets
to live longer but if Dumbledore
suddenly decided to be evil as well I
think Voldemort would be out of luck and
in reality in the existing timeline
Dumbledore didn't need dark magic he was
able to exhibit unsurpassed magical
ability while remaining entirely himself
and with no sacrifice to his soul
ultimately if we consider the Dumbledore
chose a purer path then I think that we
can reasonably infer that Dumbledore
only scratched the surface of his power
whereas Voldemort was already
capitalizing on pretty much everything
he could this is why I think that
Voldemort always feared Dumbledore the
unknown threshold of Dumbledore's power
this is why the subject of Dumbledore's
power was always a bitter pill for
Voldemort to swallow I hope that you
guys enjoyed the video what do you think
who do you believe is more powerful let
me know down in the comment section
below also for a comparison between
Grindelwald and Voldemort check out my
video which I'll show on screen until
next time remember it matters not what
someone is born but what they grow to be
foreign
[Music]